all right welcome to my tutorial on how
to build an Oxbow
Hammer first we'll take a look at the
anatomy of a hammer there's seven Parts
first we have two
heads one at either end of the hammer
and they're connected by a rope which we
call the
tether along the tether there are four
nodes which help us position our hands
as we play the two outer nodes are
called po nodes and the two inner nodes
are called Bridge nodes or shoulder
nodes
between the PO noes and the head we have
the distal
tether between the bridge node and the
point node we have the medial
tether and between the
center and the bridge node we have the
proximal
tether the bridge is the space between
the two Bridge
nodes and the yoke is the of the tether
between the two po nodes we also have
what we call the wing which is the span
of tether between the bridge node and
the
head next let's talk about how to
prepare tethers for our
build we're going to talk about cutting
them in particular because it can be
challenging so here's our
tether and we're not going to use
scissors to work with them they're too
messy um and let me just take a moment
moment to point out the nodes here so we
have a large node and a small node and
their profiles are designed for
different use cases the high-profile
node is good for lots of things the low
profile node is mainly good for Rope
Dart where you need your hand to slide
smoothly uh through the
node the tether is a/4 inch thick or 6
mm and I don't recommend going any
larger than that because air resistance
becomes a big problem and the hammer
will feel mushy when you spin it in uh
in meteor mode or Dart
mode so we're going to cut it here get
back to cutting um when we cut these
tethers they will Fray badly and we
won't be able to get the nodes back onto
the tether so we need to treat it
somehow and the best way to do this is
with
heat we're going to melt the area around
where we want to make the cut and this
will shrink and seal the fibers in place
and we'll end up with a nice tapered end
that we can use to mount the node uh
without any sort of phrase getting in
the way so go ahead and cut it here and
you can see that the result is a nice
clean tapered finish that will make
mounting the node uh much
easier
okay so next I'm going to show you
another type of fiber this is a high
performance fiber called
dyema it's very very strong and uh very
stretch resistant and it has a wonderful
feeling on the skin um the problem again
though is we can't get the Noe on until
we prepare the end and the problem with
these Advanced fibers like dyema or
technora or Kevlar is that they don't
melt they they actually sort of burn
um this dyema does melt a little bit but
it mostly Burns so when I try to cut it
here which by the way is pretty
difficult these are very strong fibers
um you'll see that we tried melting it
but that's not going to work so the
alternative is to use
tape and when we use tape I I typically
do about a uh a turn and a half to keep
it from getting too thick and then I
pull very hard on this is electrical
tape by the way pull very hard on it to
um sort of pack it all
down and now when I cut it again it's
difficult but you'll see that the end is
nice and sharp and clean and it makes it
so that the node will fit into the uh
fit over the the
tether all right now it's time to talk
about mounting the reference head so
we're going to mount one head to the end
of our tether and this will be used as
the uh starting point for building the
remainder of the the hammer from that
and um moving across the the tether so
first we'll Mount
the nodes I'm going to use blue nodes
for the PO and yellow nodes for the
bridge I treated the end of the tether
using that melting technique and you can
see that the nodes are sliding on
easily remember that the tether is a/4
in thick or about 6 mm for like Optimal
air
resistance and now we're going to start
working on the head um this is
the the outer shell it's a rubber um and
we use a cartridge system to hold it all
together and you'll see how that works
in a moment first we'll make a mark
where we want our stopper knot to go and
stopper knot is used to uh to fix the T
inside the cartridge so we made that
Mark we're going to tie the stopper knot
it's a simple overhand
knot we're going to make it really tight
so it doesn't creep on us after we've uh
we've closed everything
up just enough to fit in the cartridge
plus a little
bit we're going to open the
cartridge and place the the tether
inside with the excess facing out
and then we'll add an O-ring an elastic
o-ring and we're going to slide it all
the way back to the inboard end of the
cartridge like that and now it's
springloaded uh so it's all held
together while we work on it before we
close it up I'm twisting the tether so
that it sort of retracts into the uh
into the cartridge and now I'm adding a
weight this will be a 160 G head um I
recommend somewhere between 50 and about
g adding this little decorative sticker
to the end followed by the final o-ring
which holds it all
together and then we can just pull the
cartridge inside the
shell so that's our mounted
head and now we're going to remove it
and demonstrate adjustment so first I
pry it with my fingers and then push it
with this Sharpie a Sharpie makes a
really good tool for a lot of uh the
work you do while you're building the
hammer first we're going to pull the uh
the end o-ring off and dump everything
out remove the tether and the stopper
knot you'll notice I didn't remove the
other o-ring just to keep things
together making a mark where we want our
new knot if we want to adjust it and
you'll see we're going to slide the knot
over after loosening it
so we're taking some of that excess
tether that we had um sort of stuffed
inside the cartridge and we're we're
taking advantage of it to change the
length of the of the
tether moving the knot out would make
the hammer longer of course we're we're
adding that weight back in adding that
decorative sticker and replacing the
O-ring again we this is 160 gam head and
uh
um you know somewhere between 150 and
200 g is good 160 is a good uh starting
place there you go that's how you mount
ahead now we need to talk about setting
the first po node so we're moving
along the hammer from one end to the
other so we have a sliding node and we
have the head mounted what we're going
to do is
hold the node between our thumb and
pointer finger so that the node is in
line with the tip of our
thumb like
this we can then pull the tether in
either direction through the node while
we hold it we're going to place our
elbow on the table with the head sitting
on the surface of the table and we're
going to carefully pull the tether
through the node until until the distal
tether or the POI section of the tether
is
TT like
that we're then going
to use a screw to mount the node to the
tether but we're not going to drive it
in all the way we're only going to drive
it in about halfway and this is to
prevent damaging the tether while we
build the hammer in case we need to make
adjustments later on
so that's our first po end
finished moving along the hammer we're
going to skip the bridge nodes for now
and go to the uh the second po node we
need some space to do this so you can go
outside or into a big room or something
we're going to go into the standard Oxo
position which is a position uh where we
wrap the tether around our body in this
way you see here so it's sort of a
spiral
around our arms and around the back of
our
neck we're going to hold the PO node
just like we did before when we were
setting it so it's in line with the top
of our
thumb again the uh the head should be
parallel to the bottom of our
elbow so now you can see that the tether
is loose right now what we're going to
do is tighten it we're going to tighten
it quite a
bit pretty tight right now it'll
probably end up up being tighter in a in
a second
here so we're holding both
ends tightening the tether as we go
holding on to the tether we're going to
slide the other side the other po node
down and we're going to put it right
where we're pinching just like
that same thing Thumb in line with the
node we're going
to drive the set screw in about halfway
just to hold it in place
and now we're going to start adjusting
it as we need to to get it just
right we're going to check everything's
squared up make sure the tether is
tight while we're holding the nodes in
that nice flush
position I found it to be a little loose
in this case so I'm going to move the PO
node in
slightly so when I hold the node now
when I hold both nodes
because they're closer together it'll be
tighter around my
body it's quite tight
now still flush with my thumb now when I
move my hands down you'll see that the
node Rises up towards my wrist same on
the other
side and this is correct this is the way
it should be it should be in line with
the base of your wrist right where that
crease is in your wrist
wrist so up it's going to be tight flush
with your elbow everything looks good
down it's going to be up towards your
wrist we'll now Mount the second head to
its end of the
hammer so we have the two blue nodes
those are the PO nodes and we've set
them into their respective positions
feeling pretty good about it and now
it's time to mount the second head so
the first we're going to do is remove
the first
one again using a Sharpie to push it out
is a great way to uh to make it simpler
on yourself we're going to remove the
inboard o-ring just slide it
back break the shell
open pull the knot
out now we'll remove the head
so our objective here is to make both po
identical exactly the same length and to
do this we're just going to use our
Sharpie again to
Mark right where the first knot we tied
is located just going to make it right
in line make sure those nodes are
straight right in line right
there and we'll tie another stop or
not nice and
tight so now in theory both knots and
both nodes are exactly the same distance
apart here I'm just going to demonstrate
trimming the remainer the excess tether
off generally you would have a lot more
excess I just had a shorter uh a shorter
tether than usual but you would uh you
would
trim the excess tether away so that it
fits inside the
cartridge now we're going to mount both
heads on
oops there we
go now remember that these are
adjustable so those stopper knots can be
repositioned as necessary NE AR to
increase or decrease the length of the
uh the
PO again you'll see that I use the
O-ring I push it all the way back so
that it's like spring-loaded and that
way I can easily work with uh getting
the weight in and
keeping the excess tether out of the way
we're going to add that little sticker
again and the final
o-ring and there we have it so both po
are finished now and this establishes
the total length of the
hammer everything's lined up now we're
going to set up the Bri
brige so to do this we're going to start
working with those two yellow
nodes we'll need a
marker the first thing we need to do is
make sure the hammer is perfectly
parallel and
perfectly mirrored so to do this we're
going to line up the heads line up the
the nodes get the get the bridge nodes
out of the way sort of move them apart
from each other at decent amount line up
the PO
noes so that they're perfectly in
line and then we're going to carefully
slide both along both
tethers so that it's perfectly mirrored
so now we've arrived this is the exact
center of the hammer right here we're
going to mark it
and now we need to Center the two Bridge
nodes on either side of that Center
Point Okay so we've got them roughly in
position now we need to determine how
far apart to put them and A good rule of
thumb is to use the length of the PO
segment so laying the down we're going
to adjust the two Bridge
nodes from the
center so that the inner edge of both of
them just meets the outer edge of the
POI we're going to fold the hammer in
half and then we're going to work both
nodes so that they're lined up with each
other but we're just going to split the
difference so we're going to move one in
and one out
equally until they're perfectly in line
with each other and then we'll double
check and see it's
perfect so then we're going to use the
set screws to uh hold the nodes in place
but we won't drive them in all the way
just in case we need to make adjustments
later
on great
so there's our
Bridge we'll now check to see how the
hammer plays in various
modes so to start with let's just verify
that the hammer is well mirrored so I'm
going to fold the hammer in half and
match up the heads with each other and
then I'm going to check to verify that
the POI and Bridge nodes all line up
with each other simultaneously
so that's a good mirror and now we're
going to put on the hammer in the
standard Oxbow position making sure to
lock the tether behind our elbows like
this and you can see from behind how it
locks around the
elbow okay now we'll lower our hands to
our sides and uh we'll we'll check that
the poin noes line up with the creases
in our wrists as they did
before we'll then pinch the the PO noes
and raise our hands to our sides uh with
that 90° elbow Bend and verify that the
heads line up with the base of our
elbows hands back down we're going to
check the dynamic fit of the hammer now
so we're going to pinch the distal
tethers and it's very important to
understand that you don't use the nodes
as handles they're more like texture
markers that help you stay oriented
along the playing surface of the uh of
the tether
so we're holding the distal uh tethers
not the nodes and we're going to start
spinning in in po mode here and it's
okay if you don't know how to do any of
these movements that I'm going to show
just know that we're checking the the
length of the hammer and in this case
we're checking the length of the POI so
um the POI can this is a good starting
place at this length but if you want to
make them longer or shorter there can be
consequences um that will go over in a
little bit but hands over the head I'm
doing a windmill and you can see that
the yoke is slack around my shoulders
from the back you can see the yolk is
slack and that's normal um in fact the
POI are longer than they are when my
hands are down at my sides so if I stop
and open my hands right we've got the PO
nodes in that that standard wrist
position but if I move my hand up the
POI actually slides between my fingers
outwards and gets longer and now you'll
see that the node is in my hand when I
when I move my hand down it slides back
and now the note is at my wrist and now
it's in my fingers and now it's in my
wrist so it's important to have a nice
loose sliding grip on the tether um
we're going to escape now into a meteor
weave and we're going to check for
ground clearance so uh when the meteor
is rotating there's a center of rotation
and we want that to be in line roughly
with our shoulder that's a good
comfortable position to have it in and
um so that's our objective now there can
be problems with this if if we decided
that the poy were too short and we
wanted to make the hammer longer then we
might run into a situation where we'd be
hitting the ground um when in meteor
mode because the Hammer's too long
so I'm going to hit the ground
intentionally here so if the hammer was
too long we would be hitting the ground
and uh so you kind of have you would
have to hold your arm up to maintain
ground clearance and that's pretty much
unacceptable so you'd have no choice but
to shorten the hammer which means that
your POI would be shorter and this can
be a thing uh especially if your your
upper body is bigger like if you have a
lot of muscles in your shoulders and
arms the tether has more to wrap around
so um you have to find a good balanced
compromise between po length and meteor
length so now I'm uh doing some dart
stuff I'm holding the dart
by the bridge node and placing the head
by my hip and I'm checking for ground
clearance
here generally you want that 90° elbow
Bend again I'm going to do a more
advanced movement now this is very
difficult to pull off with a hammer
that's too long some moves are just
impossible if the hammer is too long um
so all this stuff is good I'll do a neck
roll that's also one where I hit the
ground a lot um so this is looking this
is looking pretty solid I feel really
good about where the hammer side in is
at right now and then one last thing I'm
going to do is a finger rotor in the
horizontal plane and uh you can see so
I'm checking the Bridge length right now
you can see my finger is notched into
one of the bridge nodes as I do the
rotor and I'm checking to feel the
sliding action and the friction of my
finger as it rotates around the tether
this is kind of a rabbit hole as far as
like how to place your Bridge nodes um
but basically the further apart they are
the more leverage you have and that can
be beneficial up to a limit and then you
start losing control so um yeah I think
that's about
it th this Hammer definitely fits me
well and uh you can see how I was able
to do everything so yeah so the hammer
is essentially done and all we need to
do is commit the nodes so to do that
we're just going to drive the screws in
the rest of the way and uh and then
it'll be finished so uh keep in mind
that the screws do Mar the tether ever
so slightly so um if you choose to move
them there there will probably be a
little bit of fuzz Left Behind from
where they were
prior and that's that's it so I say this
tutorial is basically done uh just uh
yeah you're going to form a relationship
with the prop and it's going to sort of
change with you over time uh you'll
you'll potentially move the nodes a
little bit here and there you might make
the tether longer or shorter uh longer
if you want to focus on po maybe and
shorter if you want to focus on meteor
and dart those sorts of things um but
yeah so thanks for watching my tutorial
and I sincerely hope you enjoy the prop
thanks a lot and hope to see you out
there